[Musique]
je te demande pour la 20e fois où tu m'a
foutu mais boutons de manchette
tu as dû les faire traîner encore c'est
un gigolo des boutons de manchette j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
mais en rien à [ __ ] à te demande pas
moi où est mon séchoir sans doute
j'étais [ __ ] gens de legris simone
manière cinq premières regardez moi s'il
vous plaît si bonnes manières gens de
les grilles vous allez bientôt rentrer
en scène votre histoire
c'est quand même au départ une belle
histoire d'amour nom sa date pas d hier
ou savez quoi on va pas parler d'année
parce que ça va pas nous aligner un peu
les deux je crois que c'est une histoire
toute simple une histoire toute bête
c'est une histoire qui est qui est fait
de tendresse des compréhension et de
respect l'un pour l'autre 3,6 me fait
dire aussi que nous avons tous les deux
la même passion pour
franchement je n'aurais pas pu vivre
avec un homme qui comme j'en aurais pas
eu une large dose d'humour et de
tendresse
non messieurs vous êtes gentil mais ça
va être en tous cas si j'étais pas là la
pièce se casserait la gueule et moi si
j'étais pas là pour souffler ton texte
qui pourrait pas nous servir le même
humour mon égard qu'il nous sert depuis
20 ans mon numéro de la gare et les
bouffées de chaleur du mois de manière
six premières simone manière gens de les
grilles on a l'impression que lorsque
vous vous embrasser sur scène vous vivez
particulièrement votre étreinte
je n'aime pas bien sûr de questions moi
je crois que s'il va très bien répondre
parce qu'elle sait bien faire ça ce que
vous voulez que je vous dise franchement
on n'en mange pas je crois franchement
aussi que le public s'y trompe pas aller
ville comme à l'écran comme on dit je
les joue dix de plus c'est un peu
embarrassant comme pc voudrais moi ça va
être à nous
[Musique]
les amoureux de l'amour on la copie
touché chargé mme berthiaume police as
m'avait tout cas pas hésité à se libérer
[Musique]
savez vous pourquoi les merveilles je ne
ris pas leur enfant sain parce que faire
bouillir les deux temps ça fait très mal
moi je ferai pas la dynastie ming
des épisodes précédents le prince lui
lui volant au secours de la princesse
nadine amouk fait une chute
spectaculaire en s'échappant de la
forteresse du temps quel état tu sais
pas si il est importante pour lui le
tchétchène mcit fête aurait quand même
pu temps passé qu'est ce que tu vas
faire maintenant mais je vais aller au
centre héliomarin hier pour retaper un
peu ils vont voir si j'ai pas des
séquelles c'est le centre des stars la
ballue lui vend surtout si je pars
glissé gagner comme ça toute ma vie
changera pas beaucoup tout en
plaisantant tout cas je l'attaqué parce
que c'est pas possible qui me poussait à
61 leur comédie partout hein parce que
c'est au moins 130 jeu l'attaquant
justin je m'adresse à lui puis comme ça
on prendra un petit peu de blé puis te
fais pas de soucis value du j'ai promis
que j'allais travailler je vais aller
travailler
je suis venir à nos besoins tu fais pas
de souci j'y vais tout de suite
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est la place de la bourse où la fille
je veux bien la bourse si je vivre je
suis encore tombé sur une enclume foutu
je suis mort n des bois le justicier
sauvage dans voici serais vous j'irais
bise
qu'est ce que tu fais je suis le
justicier sauvage je vole je vois les
pauvres pour donner aux riches mois lui
c'est petit robert
l'intellectuel du groupe et relève des
breloques à supposer que tu as là
d'aller voler les pauvres pour donner
aux riches j'ai dit à mon père et moi je
veux bien mais avec toi j'ai plein
d'adressent de peau ou sommes pas
laisser mme pas et on y va mais il
arrive vers la forêt j'ai tu acceptes
dans le groupe je vais faire pousser une
poussée coup et voilà c'est travail
aujourd'hui
adieu venise la zap tabora je t'assure
il faut travailler
j'ai une bande en france nous allons
aller voler les pauvres tout de suite et
en plus j'ai même des bijoux à l'éveil
et honnête tu sais faire la bourride
gars en avant nos cadres ont berlin
allait bien le dico à l'oubli la
princesse on a des mimiques saura-t-elle
faire la bourride vous le saurez
en regardant le prochain épisode de la
dynastie des ebooks
ils ont maintenant obsolète tous les
deux obsolète
adjectif qualificatif démodé hors
d'usagé
voir page 48 samour l on ne sait trop
pour moi
delattre tout s'est passé - nouveau
c'est qu'il faut négocier le contrat je
m'en fous une autre fois qu'est ce que
vous voulez vous êtes la nouvelle femme
de ménage nomme je suis la nouvelle
chanteuse ne manquait plus que cela jst
match très content de vous voir monsieur
l'imprésario d'une free quence parce que
figurez-vous je suis chanteuse
je n'arrive pas passée date est pas
normal
je me suis dit qu algérie costard et
plus grand imprésario qui pourrait
m'aider à passer à la télé mais vous
vous avez gardé un poids non vous avez
vous comment vous et de la beauté qu'est
ce qu'on demande des chanteuses pas du
tout ma demoiselle dont les voûtes en
plus en plus c'est pas mal mais vous
avez vous habiller comme centre rien
faire et dit mais ceci ne tricotent
sedin est là c'est la goutte et chez les
chats les parties vous venez me voir
vous foutez le camp tout de suite vous
m'écoutez sur le plus grand imprésario
vous n'avez vous m bon habillé comme
sans délai le speedling la télévision
française bat encore pour une tournée au
moyen orient gaulle maison mère
espagnole mais j'y ferai quand je
faisais rien vous êtes vous êtes
maintenant je cours
la gamme culv au merveilleux on a réussi
la danse était pas ce n'est pas facile
mais on a réussi à maintenir l normale
et la première de l'émission 1 g permet
écoute tu sais ce que je te dis tu
sentes avec ton sexe du projet ton sexe
doubler la voix chante avec un sexe j'ai
mes films je vais essayer je vous le
promets monsieur très difficile mais ça
va le faire
le public m allez allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
regardez moi me suis-je pas mes amis
joli mais je le sais en effet je suis
jolie c'est vrai
écoutez moi regardez moi je suis jolie
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fout c'est pas
possible
la dernière fois je prends une chanteuse
d'opéra exemple comme le rockeur
laquelle est dans ses vocalises
ah non c'est pas possible picoty soumise
au lycée soult isolé alors la prochaine
fois je coule l'église d'abord et après
je m'occupe du look je m'en fous moi des
toupies je m'en fous de l'ethiopie il le
rend plus vais te dire jouer à l'oeil
pour envoyer du pognon à des negro qui
ne connaissent même pas non c'est contre
- contre mes principes je suis d'accord
je fasse ça c'est complètement contraire
à la déontologie le comédien n'a pas
joué de l'artiste et puis c'est tout bon
c'est donc accepté j'ai accepté pourquoi
coiffant au passage au journal de 20
heures ou bien qu'on se fasse de la pub
c'est pas avec ton nom qu'on va se faire
de la pub non franchement je ne les
grilles six mois de manière ça deux
premières cimes mayer gens de les
grilles vous venez de faire un spectacle
profil ethiopie pourquoi
vous savez nous sommes avant tout des
saltimbanques et si en tant que certains
banques ont peu contribué à à aider des
gens qui ne mangent pas je crois que
c'est déjà pas mal je crois que c'est
réussi
ces parties de notre devoir on doit
faire ça on est des comédiens enfin je
crois ceci dit il faut peut-être pas
trop en parler ces choses là
généralement ce franc succès les
amoureux de la trame ou y ont la phobie
touchés
ira c'est le parfum de l'amour
jo mais quelques gouttes et je me sens
il résiste
fait que moi
ap
et vous serez désir
à
[Musique]
attention invité comme chaque semaine la
tremblade usines d arches grand plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui maître raoult
beyrouth avocat célèbre au barreau de
marseille m beyrouth connue évidemment
pour ses plaidoiries sans complaisance
ses prises de position politiques
quelquefois même très virulent m
beyrouth qui tout au long de sa carrière
a sauvé la vie de tous ses clients
pratiquement tous sauf un souvenez vous
la faire diesel de turbo m beyrouth qui
est aussi combattu dans les maquis n'y
de fidel castro m guirauton dit de vous
que vous êtes un homme affable quelques
choix que les re un battant en tout cas
un homme loyal venait d'avoir un enfant
un garçon et à ce propos m beyrouth
vous êtes l'auteur d'un ouvrage sorti
aux éditions du seuil un ouvrage qui a
pour titre mon fils je suis ton père
mais je peux être aussi ta mère c'est
quand même un ouvrage qui montre bien la
dualité de ces nouveaux pères ce qu'on
appelle aussi les papas poules alors
maître raul beyrouth
une question me brûle quand même les
lèvres est ce réellement un roman
autobiographique
eh bien eh bien oui bien mettre vie
route je vous remercie infiniment tout
cas d'avoir participé à cette émission
vous ne pouvez pas savoir à quel point
ça nous a fait plaisir de vous recevoir
je sais que votre temps est compté le
nôtre aussi hélas nous allons devoir
nous quitter maintenant céder la place à
un orchestre formidable leur castres
deux chambres de bonnes
[Musique]
les chercher sans retrouver
non
je les trouve
sans le cherche
[Musique]
messieurs
visage
jean mas
mais ça
[Musique]
soit
depuis quelques temps à la télévision
vous pouvez voir des garçons et des
filles à poil
il faut bien le dire pas de playmates
pas de pelé mec chez nous ici habs mais
une plèbe est un animal un animal
complètement nu et aujourd'hui le lama
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
si j'écoute la bonne les disques vendus
beaucoup plus du look
[Musique]
invité du magazine des arts pierrick et
comme tu commences à aureilhan je
connais pas encore carricart bonjour
pourquoi un film
l'invité de ce magazine des armes ce
piège
bug
[Musique]
avoir un goût basque dépliant c'est
encore moi excusez là jamais la soif
[Musique]